depuis bamako avec notre invité failli
rahman rodrigues koné bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous êtes chercheur
principal au sein de l'équipe sahel de
l'institut d'études en sécurité d'abord
quel est votre sentiment sur ce départ
départ forcé
je pense que c'est un moment important
dans la lutte contre
l'insurrection guy à 10 dans le temps
dans le sahel dont parce que la france
avait quand même un certain leadership
de l'intervention internationale
donc du coup c'est un moment historique
assez important qui peut marquer des
sérieux tournant dans la manière dont
cette lutte va se décliner
emmanuel macron refuse de parler d'échec
quel est votre sentiment quel bilan vous
vous retenez de ses 9 ans d'intervention
française et de cette guerre
je pense qu'il peut être
tôt à ses taux actuellement de faire une
ville assez précis mais on constate
qu'après neuf ans d'intervention les
résultats restent mitigés
cela dit l'engagement des troupes
françaises a été un tournant départ très
important puisque ça empêcher qu'il y
ait cette centralisation
dans tout le mali de ces groupes qui se
sont répandus peut-être progressivement
mais cela a eu quand même un certain
impact dans la manière d'autres la
menace terroriste a évolué le constat
est assez clair nous constatons que au
délà du centre du mali et nord où ses
troupes avaient étaient partis la menace
était un dieu au burkina faso ensuite
obligé et menace alors de s'étendre reçu
les pays côtiers également donc
on peut dire que les résultats sont
actuellement mitigé quel est le degré de
cette e-menace vers les pays côtiers
notamment vers vers le bénin
oui c'est assez réelle il faut se
rappeler que depuis 2010 est déjà il y
avait eu cette attaque a en côte
d'ivoire ensuite progressivement on a
commencé à avoir des attaques au
dans le nord de la côte d'ivoire ensuite
le bénin donc on voit que cette menace
et les ruelles et les pays côtiers déjà
le la côte d'ivoire le ghana
le bénin avec le mali et le burkina faso
ont déjà engagé des activités en ce sens
il ya eu l'initiative d'accor dont
l'objectif était justement une
mobilisation plus opérationnels des
armées côtières avec en collaboration
avec les pays sahéliens pour prévenir
cette menace est aujourd'hui elle est
plus que réelle donc ce redéploiement
peut s'avérer efficace selon vous
oui je dirais qu'il vient un peu
tardivement mal parce que les signaux un
peu de l'avancée de l'extension de
l'extrémisme violent sont déjà visibles
depuis longtemps on voit que ces groupes
menace de s'étendre vers l'ouest du mali
en direction du sénégal de la guinée et
mais également des pays côtiers et donc
il est très important de pouvoir
développer des stratégies d'anticipation
oui on comprend bien la seule réponse
sécuritaire ne suffira pas finalement à
endiguer ce phénomène de progression il
faut investir sur quoi selon vous
je pense qu'il aurait un tournant
important et il faut regarder de près la
stratégie que les autorités maliennes
pour mettre en place l'un des points de
tension
jetterait dans le prenais désaccord
entre les autorités maliennes les
autorités françaises s'étaient justement
cette option du dialogue est ce que le
retrait des forces françaises va
dialogue avec les jets
dialogue avec les coupes qui a disparue
s'y opposaient et maintenant peut-être
qu'il ya un champ libre est-ce que
[Musique]
sur le recours au dialogue pourrait
apaiser le champ sécuritaire si
éventuellement c'est le dialogue a été
vendu rares comment ça va se développer
dans le cas côté de l'option de dialogue
il y a également
toute la problématique du développement
d'un retour efficaces des états
dans les zones concernées la gouvernance
afin de lui jetterai la mauvaise
gouvernance a fait le lit de
l'implantation également de ces groupes
donc il ya beaucoup à faire au niveau du
développement
mais ce merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse failli rahman rodrigues connaît
depuis bamako je rappelle vous êtes
chercheur principal au sein de l'équipe
staal de l'institut d'études en sécurité